hey everyone just a quick video today I
got a question in my mastermind group in
my online masked my group and thought
i'd make a video response and been a bit
of a crazy day so I'm just recording the
response now please bear with me I have
a huge headache and so if I'm a little
less energetic than usual i hope you
forgive me so the question is about this
is a member named ty his biggest
personal obstacle he said his being a
solo entrepreneurs tiring and he needs
to have big wins to keep his confidence
going the subject motivation is a really
interesting one I think and one that
every entrepreneur needs help with at
some point and my usual advice is think
about your big why you know what's the
big goal you trying to accomplish it get
you motivated excited think about your
little wise the kind of day to day stuff
feedback from clients feedback from
customers that shows you improves
yourself that hey you do an important
work and setting up a schedule that you
know set you up for success and if you
want to be if you want to accomplish
something great you have to be
surrounded by greatness and most people
don't have greatness in their
environment from their morning routine
to the people in their lives and media
consume all of that stuff that's my
usual typical advice for motivation I
think though in reading this the vibe
I'm getting though is I don't think
that's enough you know I don't think
it's enough if you are running a
business and you are not enjoying what
you do you ought to join the process and
instead you're looking for those big
wins you get you excited you know you
can get yourself end up and motivated to
go out and do something in the short
term but that it's not sustainable like
you can only force yourself to do things
that you don't like for certain amount
of time it's not sustainable and my
thinking now is just answering your
question here is that you got to change
up the process you should enjoy what
you're doing it kind of reminds you
people who have a job will go two jabs
is ninety percent of America they go to
a job they hate it and they're living
for the weekends and evenings you know
they're waiting for their work to end so
they can go enjoy the rest of their life
that kind of reminds me of what's
happening here you know you're not
liking the work that you're doing you're
waiting for this big goal to come
that gets you excited when you hit it
and then you're deflated again I would
look at changing your business around
and either it doesn't to be as drastic
as you know closing the business going
to something new but I've been looking
at how can i modify what I'm doing in my
in my business that's so that I'm
enjoying like you should be enjoying the
work that you do and I don't have rose
colored glasses on and say that you know
every day is amazing and every day
you're full of energy and every day you
know is the best day ever you're going
to have slumps you're gonna have
problems you're gonna have days when you
doubt yourself it's all totally normal
but if all you're doing is looking
forward to those big goals and you need
those big win to keep you motivated than
something's wrong something has to
change you have to enjoy the process and
you know you're familiar with my youtube
videos so if you look at that for me i
love wednesdays once the one sit down
and do my videos i love recording the
videos i love helping answer questions i
love seeing the growth you know uh we're
gonna get over 12,000 new subscribers
this month in a YouTube channel I love
that that's amazing i'm addicted to the
growth but as much as you know that
growth fuels me i'm more excited but the
actual work I like answering the
questions I would do the work even if I
wasn't seeing massive growth because it
fills me like it feels a big part of my
heart and if I was only doing the videos
to get the growth and not because I like
them then adventure I would stop because
I didn't enjoy it right because it would
slowly be tearing pieces away from me
and yeah we hit you know another million
views in the channel and that gets you
excited for one day and you're excited
to make videos and then the next day I'm
you know back down it's not enough I
keep doing them because I enjoy doing
them and if you want to be great and you
want to have an impact and you want to
build us a really successful business
the muni be doing work that you enjoy
doing and sometimes that changes you
know maybe what you enjoy doing years
ago when you started the business is
different than what you enjoy doing that
because you as a person have changed and
grown so you got to enjoy the process
and I'm reminded of a Steve Jobs quote
where he was at Stanford University and
I'm just going to
in this clip normal would slice it in
how my editor but this is all raw stuff
so I'm just going to play it from my
computer I think it's relevant for the
past 33 years I looked in the mirror
every morning and asked myself if today
were the last day of my life what I want
to do what I am about to do today and
whenever the answer has been no for too
many days in a row i know i need to
change them your advice I hope that
helps good luck I